Today,
we're going to introduce the notion of impracticability in contracting.
We've early earlier discussed a host of formation defenses that are judged at
the time of contract formation,
but impracticability is a post formation defense that can discharge contractual
duties for events occurring after a contract is formed.
To learn about impracticability doctrine,
we examine us versus Wedge hematic corporation.
A case decided by the second circuit in 1966 back in 1956 when computers were
still relatively new,
immense mysterious technologies.
The Federal Reserve Bank invited companies to submit proposals for an electronic
digital computing system.
It's stressed and it's invitations.
The need for early delivery.
What'd geomatic corporation,
which had recently produced a successful computing system,
the Al whack three e but which nevertheless was a relative newcomer to the
industry submitted the winning proposal.
The Federal Reserve Bank and Wedge amatic agreed to a contract under the terms
of which what,
what geomatic would deliver by June 30th,
1957 nine months hence a new computer model.
The Al Whack 800 where dramatic proclaimed this would be a truly revolutionary
system utilizing all of the latest technological advances.
The Federal Reserve Board agreed to pay $231,000 for the Al [inaudible] 800
additionally,
the contract provided that wedge dramatic would pay liquidated damages of $100
per day for every day that delivery of the computer was delayed and that if
wedge geomatic failed to comply with any provisions of the agreement,
the board may procure the services described in the contract from other sources
and hold the contractor responsible for any excess costs.
Occasions thereby problems weren't long and coming in March a few a month before
the delivery date.
What dramatic suggested postponing delivery the next month,
the company wrote a letter to the board stating that due to the need for
redesign delivery would be delayed from June 30th until October 30th the letter
also requested waiver of the liquidated damages clause.
The board took the requests under advisement on August 30th,
1957 wedge dramatic wrote to the board that delivery would be delayed possibly
into 1959 unquote.
Well over a year hence and suggested use of it's al whack three e equipment
until then and again requested waiver of the liquidated damages clause.
The board did not agree to the waiver.
The nail in the coffin came in October when wedge amatic informed the board that
due to engineering difficulties,
it has become impracticable to deliver the Alek 800 computing system.
At this time,
the board managed to secure another manufacturer and about a year after Wedge
Maddix announcement,
Ibm delivered to the board a computing system serving substantially the same
functions as wedge a Maddix proposed owl whack 800 the rental price for the IBM
system was $102,000 per year with an option to purchase the equipment for
$410,000 in accordance with the terms of their contract.
The board sought damages from what dramatic a court awarded the board.
$46,300 for delay under the liquidated damages clause,
$179,000 for the excess cost of the IBM equipment and $10,000 for preperatory
expenses that proved useless and operating the IBM system.
A total of more than $235,000 in damages plus interest when geomatics soul
defense was impracticability.
It argued that delivery was made impossible by basic engineering difficulties
who's correction would have taken between one and two years and would have cost
between 1,000,001 and a half million dollars and the success of which was not
certain in making this claim,
the company relied on UCC section two six 15 that provision governing excuse by
failure of presupposed conditions provides in part that except so far as a
seller may have assumed a greater obligation delay in delivery or nondelivery in
whole or in part by a seller is not a breach of his duty under a contract for
sale if performance as agreed has been made impracticable by the occurrence of
the contingency,
the non occurrence of which was a basic assumption on which the contract was
made.
The court in an opinion by the well known judge Henry friendly,
agreed that the UCC was the proper guidance to seek on the matter,
but denied that the engineering difficulties preventing wedge geomatic from
achieving its revolutionary computing breakthrough could constitute
impracticability.
Specifically the court asserted quote,
we see no basis for thinking that when an electronic system is promoted by its
manufacturer as a revolutionary breakthrough,
the risk of the revolutions occurrence falls on the purchaser.
The reasonable supposition is that it has already occurred or at least uh,
the manufacturer is assuring the purchaser that it will be found to have have
when the machine is assembled.
The court explained the negative implications that would follow from the
defendant's argument.
Such a policy would allow manufacturers to express what are only aspirations in
order to induce agreements and gamble on mere probabilities of fulfillment
without any risk of liability.
Additionally,
the court believed that the contractual terms and language place the risk that
wedge amatic would be able to achieve its revolutionary breakthrough squarely on
wedge dramatic.
It noted the provisions allowing for liquidated damages and providing that the
Federal Reserve Bank can look to other sources in case of nondelivery.
Judge friendly also decided that quote,
if a manufacturer wishes to be relieved of the risk that what looks good on
paper may not prove so good in in hardware,
the appropriate exculpatory language is well known and often used unquote.
So what is the exculpatory language?
Uh,
that the,
uh,
judge is referring to his claim that there exists an altering rule from the
default rule that places risk on the seller and altering role that not only
exists but it's often used.
Concern comes without any citation or support and legal scholars have not
identified what the words the judge had in mind might be.
It's rather difficult indeed to imagine any parties conditioning a contract on
the occurrence of a technological revolution,
much less doing so often.
One problem is that it's going to be very difficult for contractors to prove to
a court whether a technological revolution has occurred.
In the words of Gil Scott Heron.
The revolution will not be televised but judge friendly should at least be given
credit for seeing that the doctrine of impracticability,
like the mistake drop that we studied earlier are merely default that the
parties should be able to contract around.
Indeed both the impracticability and the mistake doctrines can be seen as
default conditions to every contractual promise unless otherwise agreed.
A promise to perform is conditioned on the party's not being mistaken at the
time of formation as to a basic assumption and is also conditioned on the non
occurrence of contingencies who's not occurrence was a basic assumption on which
the contract was made.
What kinds of scenarios do you think the UCC contemplates in two six 15 as being
the types of contingency who's not occurrence was a basic assumption on which
the contract was made.
Well,
one example of a successful claim under UCC to six 15 is red river commodities
incorporated versus ides ness where the plaintiff sued EITs nest for breach
because he failed to deliver 250,000 pounds of sunflowers as required by the
contract due to a drought.
I ness only produced 75,000 pounds because it provision in the contract,
excuse the parties from performance if fire strikes accidents,
acts of God and public enemy or other causes beyond the control of the parties
took place,
the court determined that non occurrence of a crop destroying drought was a
basic assumption on which the contract was made and excused.
I'd snus performance based on UCC section two six 15 the court's reliance in Red
River commodities on the particulars of a contractual clause offering excuses
for nonperformance is important.
Normally a contracting party will not be excused under the contract default
clause or standard risk allocation clauses and less.
The clause provides for such an excuse.
By the way,
the act of the act of God clause has been sometimes defined as an an act of God
is an act that no reasonable God would do.
It's hurricanes and other weather misfortunes.
How does the UCC is impracticability provision compare to the mutual mistake
doctrine we covered earlier in the course?
One important difference is that the UCC seems to contemplate circumstances that
arise after the parties have already formed an agreement.
While a mutual mistake,
the mistake in assumption exist at the time the contract is formed.
Notably the restatement has to in practice,
but impracticability provisions section two six one which governs supervening
impracticability and it closely mirrors the UCC is provision and then there's a
second provision section two six six which concerns existing impracticability.
This provision is much closer to mutual mistake.
One difference is that under the existing impracticability provision,
no duty to perform a rises if the conditions are met while under the mutual
mistake provision to duty arises,
which is voidable by one party,
but in both cases,
if the defense has properly invoked,
there is no enforceable duty and the remedy is restitution.
Another difference is that the impracticability provision doesn't contain the
quote assumption of risk language that the mutual mistake provision contains.
However,
the restatement section two 66 does say that the provision doesn't apply if
language or circumstances indicate contrary,
which might produce the same default like result.
So what have we learned?
We introduced the concept of impracticability and examine not only the
[inaudible] provision concerning impracticability present in the wedge asthmatic
case,
but also the restatement definitions.
We compared this new doctrine with a now familiar one mutual mistake,
and we had occasion again to revisit the concepts of assumption of risk and
default and altering rules and the possible policy consequences of such rules.
Finally,
looking back at the mass to Dodick computers of the 1950s,
uh,
from the age of the smartphone that we now live in,
reminds us of a technological revolution that unlike in the wedge amatic case,
has indeed taken place.